[Música]
sólo entre el 3 y el 4% de los votantes
estadounidenses decían que seguían
indecisos a un mes de las elecciones lo
que muestra lo polarizada que está la
contienda presidencial 2020 el
porcentaje de personas que se
identifican como independientes ha caído
del 37% al 34 por ciento en los últimos
cuatro años la mayoría de los
estadounidenses se definen como
demócratas o republicanos un factor
clave donald trump 94% de los
republicanos se aprueban su gestión y
sólo el 7% de los demócratas lo hacen
las opiniones sobre barack obama también
estaban completamente divididas previo a
su reelección mientras que bill clinton
vio el 20 por ciento de aprobación entre
republicanos george w.bush cosechó
alrededor del 15 por ciento de
aprobación del lado demócrata la
separación actual es evidente sin
importar a quien apoye el 40 por ciento
de los votantes dice que no tiene amigos
en el otro lado es una división extrema
que encuentra sus raíces en el creciente
alineamiento del partido republicano con
el espectro más conservador del
electorado
según un estudio de 2019 el 36 por
ciento de los republicanos apoyan el
derecho al aborto menos del 39 en 2007
entretanto el apoyo de los demócratas al
aborto ha incrementado del 63% al 82 por
ciento lo que prueba que su demografía
ha girado a la izquierda en parte en
respuesta al éxito de las campañas de
bernie sanders para las primarias del
partido el 3 de noviembre dos visiones
radicalmente diferentes de eeuu se
enfrentan por el futuro del país